What is the cloud?
It's data.
It's scalable.
It's elastic.
It's servers, databases, and hard drives.
But it's bound in physical data centers.
We're going to unveil something that
completely changes the way you think about cloud.
You know public cloud and you may know
private cloud. And you might even know
about hybrid clouds, and marketing
clouds, and elastic clouds
,but today, now,
there's Actual Cloud.
Introducing
Google Actual Cloud Platform.
This is the world’s first cloud offering                     running on servers in the troposphere,
inside actual clouds.
It's faster, it's more scalable, it's more secure,                                                    and most importantly
it looks like a real cloud.
We're also releasing an industry first
performance feature
Stormboost.
Stormboost draws on the
power of Mother Nature
to give your persistent disks a 50%
IOPS boost during thunderstorms.
And you can predict storage performance
right from the Developers Console
by monitoring our new weather dashboard.
Or, you can just look out the window.
Google Actual Cloud Platform is the
culmination of groundbreaking scientific research
on supercooled water droplets,
technological breakthroughs in
high-altitude
ultra-low pressure chip design, and
operational efficiencies
related to the way we run
non-terrestrial datacenters.
I sleep more soundly knowing that my data is
30,000 feet above the ground.
I just love that I can see it.
This is the first step in an exciting
journey. People say the sky's the limit
but we think bigger.
The clouds are so pretty.
That's not just a cloud, Honey.
That's Google Actual Cloud Platform.
okay